learn from the tea bottle info page and
we're gonna choose under transcriptomics
RNA seek as our area of analysis the
number of options that we can choose
we're gonna keep the reference genome
we're going too fast q is the format of
the NGS data but we're going to switch
to pair n reads and human mouse is our
organism upload our file or using a URL
both upload and we get the breast cancer
education file that we downloaded from
above let's get 100% we got to find our
groups now you can choose to define
groups for analysis a number of groups
we're gonna go with no a power a priori
I defined groups so we're just gonna
cancel and we start our analysis and we
see it's highlighted in yellow that
means that's the option available to us
we're gonna go straight to map and on
transcripts both tied to here and then
I'm going to choose to two output
expression tables and then end oh we can
choose a little medical generator name
organ to name ours test run and then run
pipeline
and it's as easy as that and these
analyses normally take a little while to
run we've designed our educational files
to take about an hour to to run so
you're gonna have to come back later and
just check on my pipelines and you can
see some process and some done